hi this is presh talwalkar the october
1980 sat exam contained the following
math question
which row contains both the square of an
integer and the cube of a different
integer
you are to select the correct answer
from the following five choices
the sat is supposed to have exactly one
correct answer for each problem
however on this question the test makers
made a mistake
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
okay so the test makers intended for
there to be exactly one correct answer
which was answer choice b
this contains the number nine which is
the square of the integer three
and it contains the number eight which
is the cube of a different integer two
answer choice c was supposed to be a
distraction
while it does contain the number four
which is the square the number two and
the number eight which is the cube of
the number two
the problem with this answer choice what
they thought the problem was is that the
square and the cube are of the same
integer too so this was supposed to be a
distraction and about one quarter of the
students put this to be the correct
answer
however it was the test makers who made
the mistake
when they said you want to have the
square of an integer and the cube of a
different integer
they forgot that integers can be both
positive or negative
so the number 4 is actually the square
of a different integer if you consider
negative 2 squared and the number 8
which is the integer 2 cubed so answer
choice c does contain the square of an
integer and the cube of a different
integer so both answer choices b and c
are correct answer choices
the test makers admitted their mistake
and they actually awarded the one
quarter of the students who put answer
choice c they actually corrected their
scores and gave them an extra 10 points
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description